the interviewer of all interviewers an
immeasurable Legacy heartfelt tributes
from fans and colleagues Barbara Walters
iconic journalist and long time
television staple has died at the age of
93. outlets such as variety reported her
death on the evening of December 30th
2022 with her publicist confirming her
passing Walters was a Trailblazer in the
field of broadcast journalism getting
her start way back in the 1950s and
steadily climbing her way to the top in
1974 she became co-host of The Today
Show two years later she famously became
the first woman to co-anchor a major
evening United States news program when
she joined Harry Reasoner on ABC evening
news in the decades that followed
Walters continued to leave her mark on
both TV and news history She interviewed
a who's who of pop culture and political
notables ranging from presidents like
Richard Nixon to act singer Barbara
Streisand resulting in numerous on-air
moments worthy of multiple viewings not
to mention she was a driving force
behind 2020 and the view for years
continuing to keep audiences informed
and entertained simultaneously suffice
to say her influence cannot be
understated and her enduring impact on
the media landscape will be felt for
years to come
born in Boston Massachusetts on
September 25th 1929 Barbara Walters went
through the public school system before
pursuing higher education
post-graduation following her graduation
from Sarah Lawrence College she got busy
trying to find work this eventually led
her to the station now known as wnbc
setting her on a career path that she'd
flourish in by the start of the 1960s of
course while Walters excelled in front
of the camera as a news anchor when one
thinks of the famed journalist chances
are they're reminded of her many
celebrity interviews a handful of which
had become the stuff of Legend arguably
one of her most widely known interviews
is the one with actress Catherine
Hepburn after struggling to get the
Oscar collecting Hepburn to agree to an
interview Walters finally got the
opportunity to do so while Hepburn
offered some fascinating insights all
folks seem to remember the interview for
is Walters asking her which kind of tree
she feels she would be other noteworthy
segments include her special with former
Cuban leader Fidel Castro and her chat
with Monica Lewinsky in the wake of the
Scandal involving her and then U.S
President Bill Clinton but they're just
the tip of the iceberg when it comes to
her truly countless interviews by the
start of the 2010s Barbara Walters began
to lighten her workload with retirement
on the horizon sure enough by the middle
of the decade her career officially came
to an end and she had nothing to be
ashamed of between the news programs she
hosted the figures She interviewed and
the accolades she collected Walters
enjoyed a career like no other she will
be sorely missed following the
announcement of Barbara Walters death
several celebrities friends and fans
began to pay tribute to the late
broadcaster NBA superstar Kareem
Abdul-Jabbar took to Twitter to praise
her efforts in pursuing the truth Jabar
wrote before noting how she inspired an
entire generation of journalists Barbara
Walters never flinched when questioning
the world's most powerful people she
held them accountable we are all better
off because of her fellow journalist and
television personality Oprah Winfrey
opened up about the influence Walters
had on her career on Instagram sharing a
photo of the two Oprah said without
Barbara Walters there wouldn't have been
me nor any other woman you see on
evening morning and Daily News several
other celebrities mourn the loss of one
of journalism's most iconic players
including Wonder Woman star Linda Carter
who described Walters as quote an
American institution who opened the door
to endless possibilities for so many
girls who wanted to work in TV as the
news of her death made its way through
various pockets of social media fans
began to post some of Walter's most
memorable moments
vulture's Wolfgang roof fondly
remembered how Walters called the
Kardashian family untalented in a
damning interview while a Twitter user
shared a playful video of the
broadcaster giving pop sensation Beyonce
five dollars to sing for her perhaps the
most fitting tribute to cement Walter's
Legacy is one that took place nearly a
decade ago during her final appearance
as a co-host on The View in 2014 her
colleagues in Winfrey brought out over a
dozen female journalists to thank
Walters for her trailblazing efforts the
tribute to the journalist went viral
following her death
[Music]